it turned out to be they didn't have
enough evidence to actually
um finish them off at trial so he he was
found innocent
yeah yeah but he wasn't innocent of
beating those you know cheeks up
non-stop 24 7.
[Music]
Donald Trump has been indicted in New
York City
I don't know these big adults he got
arrested is that what does indicted mean
it wasn't dying I don't even know he got
captured so he that sounds crazy but he
has been um there's a grand jury yeah
who came back with all these charges
that he has to face criminal charges and
they're basically saying hey we have
evidence that he is guilty of charges
It's all under seal so we don't know
what the charges are yet
um but isn't it for the [__] the hush
money the 100 yeah
but we don't know what the specific
charges are right he there's many
charges I think there's like 31 or
something like that really yeah but um
but yeah the story is that
um he paid Stormy Daniels a sum of money
over like it was like 100 something 130
Grand or something like that
um like just before he started running
for president
and the idea is like he this is maybe a
campaign Finance violation because he
paid her to keep quiet about something
that could influence or impact his
campaign now what he's saying is I did
this to keep myself from like like in
personal embarrassment like like my wife
and like I like people know me and like
I don't want them to think that and then
so that's the distinction right now I
think he also said that it wasn't
campaign money that he paid with correct
it was Michael Cohen his his ex attorney
paid for this with his own personal
money and then they're they're claiming
that maybe he was reimbursed by the
Trump campaign so it's another part of
it but then
um if you how do you determine you know
what Donald Trump was thinking and
that's kind of where a lot of legal
Minds have some thoughts where it's like
well he obviously was trying to silence
this woman because he knew he was
running for president versus we don't
know that he was trying to do that we
know he was definitely trying to save
himself from personal embarrassment
but nobody definitely knows so so he was
he's he's not denying that he paid her
no he is he is he's denying that he paid
her he says he's a his attorney Peter
and he didn't know anything about it he
had nothing to do with it okay okay so
he's saying that like just as a
precaution the attorney paid her it's
almost like he's not denying that she
got paid I'm Bart's attorney
Bart is busy with barbell Bart's busy
with JK Bart's like hey there's
something
um that I need you to handle I don't
know anything about it and then I just
go handle it okay right and so then he
then the methods that I handle it with
Bart's not privy tube necessarily yeah
what's funny is the thing is people are
like also saying you know he falsified
business documents I'm like I highly
doubt that fool's on Excel and also
[__] you know I highly doubt [__]
Donald Trump is on a computer [__]
typing away with his two fingers about
like false family doesn't even use
emails actually if he was typing it does
seem like he would do it with two things
all right and then he's all like doing
this and he's falsifying numbers
documents all the all the stuff while
laughing evil laughs I'm like this guy
[__] grew up rich he probably has a
team with a team and his team has a team
100 you know and he's used to this like
fixer stuff right yeah when things like
this happen how come the people that did
it get it did it get it get in trouble
how come the person at top does well and
there's an argument to be made about you
know we've talked about this over the
years something that always gets ducked
is the Congressional slush fund there's
a sexual harassment fund for congress
they paid out millions of dollars to
like Pages Congressional Pages interns
all that stuff and is that not campaign
Finance violations that's like the part
of the pushback is like why aren't those
people being in charge of campaign
Finance violations like this stuff
happens a lot in politics this is kind
of a common thing in politics is what
people are saying but then some other
people are saying well this clearly
protected Trump's campaign from
embarrassment and so if not for this
happening saying Trump wouldn't have won
or like even maybe been nominated in the
Republican party and who knows because
there's a lot of Hardcore Christians in
the Republican party but they also
didn't seem to give a [__] when he was
being accused of this during the
campaign
okay well just again in my political
ignorance and all that stuff regardless
of the truth what does uh indicting
Trump have as a you know like what's
gonna happen so he's Presumed Innocent
he's he's innocent until proven guilty
right so so he has to be tried I guess
uh what would be a motive so to speak
for some rudest chances ruin his chances
of running because he's ahead he's the
basically the the highest chances of the
Republican party because I don't think
some one who's who's going through like
charges can actually run for president I
think that's a technicality like if
you're in the middle of a case like
dealing with like a murder case or
accusation or whatever I think not like
if it's not perception that hurts you
like people's like oh this guy's a
[__] crook then um you can't be
charged with a felony if you're charged
a felony you're out yep and but if it's
a misdemeanor which this this you know
we'll see what happens obviously
um but this isn't you know this is going
to be brought up as potentially a felony
and they can use it toward uh smearing
your campaign because they're like it's
a criminal complaint yeah if if you want
this guy to be your president so I think
leading up to the election it could be a
tactic for that
yeah but there's a and there's a lot of
thoughts too about how you know this is
done so often in campaign Finance stuff
like John Edwards you guys remember John
Edwards is John Edwards was a front
runner in the 2004 presidential campaign
with John Kerry he ended up being his
running mate for vice president they
lose Obama wins later on and they get
John Edwards for a campaign Finance
violation similarly to to Trump the the
Obama's
um doj charges John Edwards with a
campaign Finance violation because they
paid a woman
um who John Edwards was like [__] on
Big Time well his wife had like cancer
oh that's right yeah he's beating he's
beating those cheeks up right yeah
because he didn't want to [__] no cancer
person yeah he didn't want to [__]
cancer [__] anymore because he thought
it was all dried up yeah but then he
didn't want chemo dick he didn't yeah
yeah exactly and so then you know he's
like beating those flaps up right he's
like he's like he's like basically
motorboating this talented [__] yeah
but then you know his campaign's like yo
we gotta pay this [__] to go the [__]
away like them beef curtains is worth
money and then and then it turned out to
be they didn't have enough evidence to
actually
um finish him off at trial so he he was
found innocent
yeah yeah but he wasn't innocent at
beating those [__] cheeks up non-stop
24 7. did he deny that he had a smirk he
was like I [__] that he's like I
[__] it he's like I took it to Waffle
House to get it more energy and then I
[__] it again he's like my wife's in
the whole Make-a-Wish [__] she ain't she
ain't horny no more like they're taking
my wife to SeaWorld I don't know what
they're doing
I like the refueling at the Waffle House
yeah that's my favorite fancy World well
that's where his wife went she wanted to
see her last Shamu show yeah she was a
big fan and she realized they [__]
took out the whole show and she was like
what the [__] before they got canceled
from a conspiracy theorist perspective
is there anything to mainstream media
putting this at the front running of
their news source in order to I don't
know per se hide some other not real
sure there's nothing to that no yeah
cause this I looked it I just Googled it
no chat gpt4 said no Yep this is the big
news what about when Donald Trump called
Stormy Daniels a horse face what about
that uh which time
yeah he's just been done he's done it
for the amount of times there's been
president so 46 times
what an absolute Legend can we go back
to the John Edwards in the beef curtains
part yeah yeah so he was like really
rough housing that thing he pulled he
pulled her flaps too
took thrust into it oh what he put a
saddle over that [__] and he apparently
allegedly was wearing stirrups yep it
was in the court document
s you guys want to read the transcripts
yeah and by the way this we only know
that about this because of Discovery
yeah where both sides have to show all
the information and they have to go into
detail the sexual details yep yeah and
motive you know he had a 12 gallon hat
and you guys know why why well he
couldn't come that much
that's not what I was thinking what's up
with you
got it at the tourist store okay got it
got it got it got it crazy it's just the
story such a wild [__] goose chase I
don't understand the double standard
though because I'm like how you gonna go
and accuse someone of something your cap
already does it's like is this part of
the game huh yeah just take it all out I
saw this one thing right where they put
um Alex Jones on trial about how his
like
um basically they're just like you know
um did you really say this about
pedophiles like did you say that
Washington is full of pedophiles and he
goes oh you mean like how Epstein
um and Clinton and all them got together
yeah and then the [__] lawyers were
like
oh and by the way this is how Jones that
trial the whole time he's just like
and like he is literally like the Moon
Man
I don't like [__] kids but Moon men do
and then but then he's a trial and
they're like they're like yeah we think
you did all this [__] he's like what the
[__] are they talking about it's crazy
you have a good Alex Jones right he's
like he's like the whole Moon
did you like did you buy expensive shoes
that we can liquidate and he's like what
the [__]
let's absurd [__]
[Music]